[Música]
en Primera Plana
Carlos Serrano
[Música]
Bienvenidos en primera plano un programa
de radiofrance internacional y de France
24 esta semana con el foco puesto en la
más Rabiosa actualidad con lo que está
sucediendo en Perú con esa crisis
abierta con la destitución y la
detención del hasta ahora presidente
Pedro castillo y la crisis abierta un
país que vive permanentemente casi en la
crisis política nos acompañan en este
estudio lizel Quirós historiadora
especialista en América Latina de la
Universidad de sergi bienvenida Gracias
Carlos
periodista independiente especializado
en Latinoamérica que por cierto ha
estado en las elecciones locales en seis
ciudades peruanas durante el mes de
octubre bienvenido guillón Muchas
gracias y Danae rivadeneira compañera
peruana de la redacción de radiofrance
internacional bienvenida qué tal Carlos
la crisis de Perú hoy nuestro asunto en
Primera Plana
[Música]
Perú parece instalado en una crisis
política permanente pero lo de esta vez
Parece ser un episodio especialmente
grave el hasta ahora presidente Pedro
Castillo acabado detenido acusado de
rebelión después de su fallido intento
de disolver El Congreso y decretar Un
gobierno de excepción en el año y medio
de mandato del izquierdista el
legislativo controlado por la derecha
hizo tres intentos de moción de
destitución el expresidente y el
gobierno amenazaron con más de una vez
con disolver el congreso y enfrentaron
una crisis interna que hizo que se
renovara el gabinete hasta en cinco
ocasiones Lo cierto es que Perú y sus 33
millones de habitantes llevan seis años
sumidos en una crisis institucional
profunda con la corrupción como telón de
fondo repasemos algunas portadas que nos
deja esta crisis diario comercio
boluarte ASUME la presidencia y detienen
al golpista castillo que podría
enfrentar 20 años de cárcel Clarín el
presidente del Perú fue destituido tras
intentar un autogolpe que duró dos horas
correo de Perú portada del pasado
miércoles antes de que todo sucediese
todo podrido nuevo escándalo revelado
con hembra de Castillo aquí en Europa
también eco en la prensa artículo del
país Pedro Castillo un año y medio a la
deriva en Perú Bueno lo primero me
gustaría que me contaran Cómo han vivido
estas horas frenéticas que ha habido
Perú no sé lisel estamos ante uno de los
episodios más tensos de la historia del
país estamos ante uno de los episodios
más tensos de la historia del país que
nos ha preocupado y nos preocupa mucho
porque es como lo acabas de señalar algo
que está durando y que se ya se vuelve
un algo como que constante una constante
en la historia del Perú en que estemos
con inestabilidad política que no
podamos tener una tranquilidad para
construir un país
más equitativo mucho más justo y eso es
una gran preocupación una pena como
peruana y preocupación también de lo que
nos espera el los desafíos tan grandes
que nos esperan en estos próximos días
vamos a analizarlo todo en Primera Plana
Castillo decidió patear el tablero en un
sorpresivo mensaje
televisado y la instalación de un
gobierno de excepción vamos a llamarlo
bueno intento fallido de autogolpe como
queráis pero no nos vamos a centrar
tanto en como lo denominamos sino en las
causas por qué toma esa decisión
Castillo Por qué decide esa huida hacia
adelante Cuáles eran las motivaciones yo
creo que Pedro Castillo no tiene otra
salida al era una de sus últimas cartas
que tenía que jugar a este este momento
porque era la tercera moción de de de
destitución y él sabía que bueno podía
pasar y tenía tenía que que no sé por
qué lo hizo a este momento pues no
parece que fuera a perder tampoco y ya
la había enfrentado en otras ocasiones
No sí hay algo pero a un momento él
sabía él sabía porque hay en las últimas
horas hay ministros también que
renunciaron también entonces se
encuentra también aislado también
aislado bastante y tenía que jugar una
de esas cartas yo creo que fue de
últimos minutos hasta sorprendió
sorprendido bastante fue la del Perú y
en Perú también tanto en la clase
política porque yo pienso que hay
bastante congresista que no iban a votar
en favor de yo creo que hubo un
ingrediente que hizo que él cambiara y
que dijera es probable que esta moción
de censura Sí la voy a perder pasa es
que hubo un testigo que se iba a
presentar al congreso que se presentó al
congreso y que por primera vez alguien
dijo yo le he entregado 450 mil soles
cien mil euros más o menos al presidente
de la república para de Tales actos de
corrupción Entonces era la primera vez
que alguien daba su cara que era el jefe
de del gabinete de asesores del
Ministerio de de vivienda que lo decía
entonces claro eso sí podía inclinar
totalmente la balanza y él podía perder
la moción de censura Entonces él dice
claro es muy probable y además se sabe
también que él ya estuvo sondeando la
posibilidad de en fin de de cerrar el
congreso y ver si tenía el apoyo del
ejército y de o de la policía claro
según vayamos vayan pasando los días yo
me imagino que vamos a ir conociendo
partes de la entrehistoria que todavía
se nos escapan de todo esto hoy muy
interesante hoy creo que lo publicado el
diario El País una entrevista muy buena
con el consejero Luis Alberto Mendieta
que fue consejero de Castillo casi hasta
que al final le pasa el documento del
texto que debía leer y no y no no lo lee
Castillo sino que lee otro texto y él
habla de una un nubilación irracional
que entra en el terreno del
psicoanálisis es decir incluso entramos
en cuestiones del propio Castillo que a
lo mejor se nos escapan no probablemente
porque somos seres humanos y personas
que estamos afectados por lo que sucede
y como lo comentábamos
que así yo ha vivido también una
situación Durante un año y cuatro meses
de acoso también psicológico es decir
que no se le ha dejado trabajar ha
estado constantemente puesto en causa no
ha habido un
hay también un contexto de fuerte
racismo y clasismo no se puede negar no
puede justificar
pero si me estás preguntando si ese y
ese factor puede tener un peso un peso
un peso en su decisión no en la
justificación de la decisión sino la
decisión si puede ser es decir le puede
haber afectado también seguramente o sea
como persona De hecho no ahora bueno es
también un poco lo que se espera eso de
señalar que tiene problemas
de salud Pero puede ser que también sea
algo real claro esa parte también sigue
Castillo había anunciado ese autogolpe
Como hizo en su día fujimori pero a
diferencia de fujimori no tenía el
respaldo que si tuvo fujimori No claro
un estudio justamente
75% tiene una desconfianza entre cuando
con Pedro castillos
según un estudio justamente que que
salió hace hace una semana Yo creo que
él quiso quiso Bueno a un momento
decirse si no lo hago Ahora
va a ser muy tarde después y hay un
riesgo entonces tengo que hacer y
justamente hablamos de fujimori este 5
de abril de 1992 cuando fujimori tenía
la aprobación y está estamos también en
un Perú que es totalmente diferente de
ahora
que él hace no una una apuesta también a
su son sus últimas cartas y si no la
última no O sea Definitivamente ya se
dice se ve
sin el apoyo de los medios ni del
ejército ni de los poderes Entonces
el pueblo peruano pueblo peruano
que las bases podían ser un respaldo y
además también apoyarse en el alto nivel
de desaprobación que tiene el congreso
es decir que se vayan todos es una frase
que se repite mucho a cada cierto tiempo
en Perú y se refieren a los congresistas
que se vayan todos y los representantes
políticos Entonces yo creo que Castillo
lo que ha querido hacer es decir Ok que
se vayan todo juego eso voy a cerrar el
congreso la gente va a estar a favor
porque todo mundo desaprueba el congreso
y mis bases campesinas los que me han
elegido y me han puesto aquí me van a
defender que Marchena lo que pasa es que
es muy peligroso en valorar la escena
política es que son jugadores muy
peligrosas de democracia yo creo que hay
una cosa muy importante también que
entender es que si lo hubiera hecho una
semana dos tres cuatro días antes
hubiera sido totalmente yo creo
diferente Que este día mismo donde al
congreso se estaba estudiando justamente
esta esta cuestión
Puede ser Es peligroso para el mismo
tiempo o sea lo que están viviendo
también millones de peruanas y de
peruanos es como una suerte de no
reconocimiento de su posición o sea este
Esto sí si un movimiento social se va a
organizar y definitivamente tenemos
referentes en la región y chile es una
referencia importante en el Perú si hay
un estallido Social es más global no
solamente es la responsabilidad de Pedro
Castillo es también Es sobre todo la
responsabilidad de toda la clase
política peruana que está completamente
cerrada a todo tipo de cambio y y de
democratización también porque todos
estos
el congreso ha salido victorioso
Aparentemente de de esta de este
episodio Pero sabemos bien que todos los
parlamentarios todos los congresistas
tienen procesos por corrupción todos
están involucrados en ese tipo de cosas
entonces bueno que se solicite al pueblo
puede o sea de alguna forma también se
puede ver desde una perspectiva como que
la democracia es eso Buscar también el
apoyo popular porque
es la desconexión que hay entre lima y
el resto de Perú no limas como un mundo
aparte y el peligro que hay ahora que
las bases puedan movilizarse a partir de
ahora no sé si ese riesgo se están
teniendo en cuenta ahora mismo en Perú
claro Yo pienso que la base la base que
él tiene hoy día no es la misma que él
tenía justamente Al momento de su
elección y lo podemos mirar con la
popularidad
encontraron figuras muy histriónicas No
sí y declaraciones polémicas también
investigaciones también que eso el papel
de la prensa también en Perú es muy
importante ha jugado bastante Y eso yo
lo vi yo yo cuando voy en Perú cada
persona en los pueblitos en hasta en las
chacras como como llamamos eso en Perú
lee la prensa y y a veces no tiene
absolutamente la televisión y lo que ve
es corrupción corrupción corrupción Y
eso ha jugado bastante esos últimos años
no formando protesta a fuerzamente pero
a crear un rechazo hacia la política no
solo de Pedro Castillo pero en general
yo creo que eso fue muy evidente por
ejemplo durante las elecciones es algo
que quedó muy muy marcado la
polarización que que se percibía era
sumamente fuerte pero también claro
encarnadas por los medios y yo no lo
podía ver en el tiempo que le daban por
ejemplo a Pedro castillo y que le daban
a keiko fujimori era increíblemente el
desbalance que que había en ambos casos
y luego cuando Pedro fue elegido que
ningún estudio de opinión lo había
siquiera monitoreado ni siquiera había
una foto de él o sea
cómo es posible los estudios de opinión
no había nada entonces ahí para hablar
acerca de desconexión Lima regiones
totalmente y lo cual es puede explicar
precisamente su su gesto o sea decirse
ahora Necesitamos explicarnos
Sí por supuesto No desde su punto de
vista justifica para él que entonces
solicite porque ya estaba bajando
también en términos de popularidad y
esto puede generar más bien un apoyo
Porque las se ve como una injusticia O
sea desde fuera de Lima como algo
Injusto Y como siempre la capital
dirigiendo todo porque también tenemos
eso Lima no y el resto del país entonces
puede ser que eso también hay que ver
estas estas semanas estos días que
vienen van a ser su futuro judicial
ahora se enfrenta una acusación por
rebelión y podría enfrentarse apenas de
10 y hasta 20 años no y ha pedido el
asilo a México No sí son es cierto o sea
y luego lo que vamos a ver seguramente
es que hay más carros que se van a que
se van a ir sumando eso se va a ir
viendo efectivamente en los próximos
días a todo esto el congreso aprobó que
la nueva presidenta la primera mujer en
la historia del Perú sea Dina boluarte
Quién es Dina boluarte
es una abogada de 60 años que
recientemente había sido ministra y
que ASUME la vicepresidencia de manera
es una mujer que tampoco es de Lima no
es una mujer para nosotros en el Perú
chola es decir que tiene raíces
indígenas y que entonces va a tener
frente a ella un desafío enorme Porque
siendo mujer y con las demás
características que acabo de señalar su
tarea es ardua por no decir
vamos a hablar de los retos que tiene
por delante Pero va a ser a vuelta de
una pausa que en Primera Plana
[Música]
en Perú el nuevo gobierno declaró del
estado de emergencia durante 60 días en
siete provincias en un intento por
controlar las protestas por el proceso
contra el destituido presidente Pedro
Castillo son varios los fallecidos en
las movilizaciones al tiempo que el ex
jefe de estado envió una contundente
carta desde prisión ampliamos desde Lima
el presidente Nicolás Maduro felicitó a
las delegaciones del gobierno colombiano
y la guerrilla del eln que finalizaron
su primer ciclo de conversaciones
llevado a cabo en Caracas los
negociadores indicaron que se prevé que
la siguiente fase del proceso se lleve a
cabo en México
en Chile el congreso acordó una nueva
hoja de ruta para el proceso
Constituyente tras más de tres meses de
negociaciones en principio se creará un
nuevo órgano redactor llamado consejo
constitucional con integrantes elegidos
por la ciudadanía y veinticuatro
congresistas que participarán como
expertos ampliamos desde Santiago
Bienvenidos a este informativo con las
noticias más relevantes del continente
americano soy Valentina Torres Sánchez y
es un gusto acompañarlos comenzamos con
la tensa situación que vive Perú tras la
declaración de estado de emergencia en
siete provincias varios muertos en las
protestas contra el gobierno de Dina
boluarte decenas de policías heridos en
medio de choques en las manifestaciones
y la contundente carta enviada por el
destituido presidente Pedro Castillo
desde prisión donde califica boluarte de
Usurpadora desde Lima Francisco Zacarías
nos amplió detalles de la situación
el gobierno de la presidenta Dina
boluarte decretó el estado de emergencia
por 60 días en siete provincias de la
región Apurímac han sido suspendidos
algunos derechos constitucionales para
que las fuerzas de seguridad puedan
poner orden y frenar los actos de
vandalismo que llevan ya siete muertos a
lo largo de estas jornadas según la
defensoría del pueblo alrededor de 15
policías resultaron heridos después de
un ataque con explosivos por parte de
bandalos que piden la libertad del
expresidente Pedro Castillo la renuncia
de la presidenta Dina boluarte y el
cierre del Congreso lo de bordes
violentos de hoy bloquearon tramos de la
carretera Panamericana tomaron un
aeropuerto incendiaron una fiscalía una
comisaría y secuestraron a dos policías
en Lima fueron atacadas las
instalaciones de Panamericana televisión
América Televisión y el canal n los
manifestantes también atacaron a una
unidad móvil de radio exitosa por su
parte el ministro del interior César
Cervantes afirmó que hay 24 400 personas
involucradas en las protestas en todo el
Perú y elevó la cifra de policía heridos
a 44 el ministro Cervantes reveló que se
evalúa la presencia física de las
fuerzas armadas en las calles bajo el
comando de la presidenta Dina boluarte
para intentar poner orden a la situación
el lunes 12 de diciembre finalizó en
Venezuela el primer ciclo de
conversaciones entre el gobierno
colombiano y la guerrilla del eln las
negociaciones fueron retomadas en
noviembre de este año y pretenden
finalizar un conflicto de casi 60 años
por su parte El Ejecutivo de México
confirmó su disposición para realizar
una segunda fase en su país a principios
de 2023 Andrés triviño nos cuenta más
como una luz de Esperanza así
describieron el gobierno de Colombia y
la guerrilla del eln la finalización del
primer ciclo de negociaciones en su
intento por lograr un acuerdo de paz
definitivo entre las dos partes luego de
21 días de reuniones a Puerta cerrada
acordaron cuatro puntos incluyendo el
reconocimiento de la grave situación de
violencia en los territorios y atención
de emergencia en departamentos como el
Valle del cauca y chocó las partes
reconocen la grave situación de
violencia que se presenta en los
territorios Y decidieron poner en
ejecución un acuerdo parcial de atención
de emergencias que iniciará a partir de
enero del 2023 las conversaciones de
Park reiniciaron el pasado 21 de
noviembre en Caracas con la intención de
finalizar un conflicto de casi seis
décadas el primer acercamiento se
realizó en el 2017 durante el gobierno
de Juan Manuel Santos pero fue
suspendido en el 2019 durante el mandato
de Iván Duque luego de que el perpetuará
un ataque que dejó a 22 policías muertos
el apoyo internacional ha jugado un
papel crucial en estas nuevas
negociaciones recientemente los
gobiernos de México y chile se sumaron a
Cuba Noruega y Venezuela como garantes
mientras que Alemania Suecia Suiza y
España son acompañantes el respaldo que
recibe esta mesa por parte de la
comunidad internacional es muy
importante Nosotros le hemos dicho que
lo agradecemos Y como dice su palabra
nos acompañan y nos reemplazan los
esfuerzos de los colombianos para que
esta tarea de la paz recaiga ese hombros
de las dos delegaciones por su parte el
gobierno mexicano confirmó que la
próxima Ronda de negociaciones se
realizará en su país a partir de enero
en las cuales se espera lograr un cese
al fuego bilateral
y continuando con temas que involucran a
Colombia y a Venezuela el presidente
Nicolás Maduro anunció que a partir del
primero de enero de 2023 la frontera
entre ambas naciones quedará
completamente abierta para permitir el
paso de vehículos particulares lo que no
ocurre desde 2015 maduro informó además
que actualmente están ultimando
preparativos para cumplir todo lo
acordado con su homólogo Gustavo Petro
desde agosto
puedo anunciar
Que estaremos abriendo completamente la
frontera
de todo el occidente de Venezuela con
Colombia para cumplir la palabra
empeñada con el presidente Gustavo Petro
de aperturarla el primero de enero
empezando el año 2023 para que esa
fronteras queden bueno
funcionales libres en Chile tras meses
de negociaciones El Congreso acordó la
creación de un nuevo órgano redactor
para la nueva constitución que busca
acabar con la heredada de la dictadura
en una segunda oportunidad luego de que
la convención constitucional redactara
un borrador de Carta Magna que fue
rechazado en consulta popular a la
ciudadanía desde Santiago Patricia Luna
corresponsal de France 24 nos dio los
detalles
98 días después de que los chilenos
acudieran de forma masiva un plebiscito
Y rechazaran de forma contundente con un
62% una nueva propuesta constitucional
destinada a reemplazar a la polémica
Constitución de Augusto pinochet que
Data en el país desde 1980 la mayoría de
los partidos que forman parte del
Congreso chileno presentaron en la noche
de este lunes un acuerdo y
constitucional y un nuevo itinerario
para una nueva propuesta constitucional
se trataría de un consejo constitucional
formado por 50 miembros elegidos por
sufragio universal de forma paritaria
con voto obligatorio en unas elecciones
que si se cumplen itinerario estarían
previstas en abril de 2023 al que le
precedería una comisión de expertos
formado por 24 miembros 12 elegidos por
la cámara de diputados y 12 por el
senado que tendría como trabajo elaborar
un anteproyecto sobre el que luego
trabajaría este consejo constitucional
al que se sumaría también la comisión de
expertos y se los brazos en seis meses
este órgano debería proponer un nuevo
texto constitucional que se basa en 12
puntos previos ya acordados que deben de
cumplirse y que marcan una serie de
normas básicas y debería estar
aproximadamente si los plazos son
cumplidos en octubre de 2023 a partir de
ahí un mes más tarde se convocaría a un
nuevo plebiscito de salida también con
voto obligatorio en lo que sería ese
segundo intento de reemplazar la
polémica Constitución de Augusto
pinochet que Data todavía en el país y
sigue vigente vamos ahora sí porque
entre lágrimas el presidente electo Luis
Ignacio Lula da Silva recibió el diploma
que lo acredita como ganador de las
presidenciales el próximo mandatario
condenó lo que llamó el legado perverso
de Yahir bolsonaro y destacó la valentía
de las autoridades electorales para
defender la democracia pese a las
amenazas y ofensas de los bolsonaristas
Lula ASUME el cargo el próximo primero
de y así se pronunció en su discurso de
aceptación
Haré todo lo posible junto con mi
querido colega geraldo alkinín
para cumplir con el compromiso que
asumimos solo durante la campaña sino a
lo largo de toda mi vida para ser de
Brasil un país más desarrollado y más
justo
con garantía de dignidad y calidad de
vida para todos los brasileños
especialmente para las personas más
necesitadas
la policía de Bahamas arrestó a San Bang
pan Frida el fundador y ex presidente
ejecutivo de eft una de las firmas más
grandes de criptomonedas que se declaró
en quiebra en uno de los colapsos de
mayor perfil en la industria
criptográfica la fiscalía general
estadounidense reveló a su vez que
entregó a Bahamas notificación formal de
cargos criminales contra El joven de 30
años que ya ha negado haber cometido
fraude y que podría solicitar su
extradición FX Se declaró en quiebra en
noviembre después de que sus
inversionistas retiraran millones de
dólares en apenas tres días tras salir a
flote una crisis de liquidez que según
la justicia habría sido originada por
desvíos de dinero de bankman hacia otras
de sus empresas
así llegamos al final de esta
informativa ustedes Gracias por su
sintonía continúen con nosotros
[Música]
seguimos en Primera Plana analizando la
crisis que nos marca la actualidad la
crisis de Perú con lisel Quirós
historiadora guillón mascar y periodista
independiente que ha estado para las
elecciones locales en Perú en el mes de
octubre y nuestra compañera Danae
rivadeneira
Bueno pues Castillo decidió patear el
tablero en ese sorpresivo mensaje
televisado estamos
analizando todo lo que ha conllevado
esta situación ahora Dina boluarte es la
primera mujer presidenta en el Perú la
abogada va a ser encargada de liderar
esta etapa de transición hasta que se
celebren nuevas elecciones no sé si la
pregunta ahora es si se va a agotar el
mandato guillón
hay un duda una duda una duda muy grande
sobre sobre si va a acabar el mandato
Cómo va a pasar en la creo que las
próximas horas la próxima los próximos
días van a ser clave para ver Porque
primero hay dos cosas en vicepresidente
de Castillo segundo es de Perú libre hay
que ver cómo se va a organizar Cómo se
va a formar este juego de Alianza porque
sabemos que en Perú la alianza entre los
partidos es muy importante para Para
proponer algo Si no vamos a seguir una
crisis permanente lo que lo que seguir
organizar un gobierno de unidad de
unidad de unidad nacional Perdón eso ya
es un gran desafío para empezar apuestan
por elecciones anticipadas
2026 pues en realidad es complejo saber
o sea Dina boluarte de hecho hasta antes
de ser nombrada bueno presidenta ha sido
como una pieza de choque en realidad de
hecho a la fiscal de la nación la ha
llamado golpista O sea hay Fuentes que
dicen también que ya estuvo detrás de
organizarla que que pedido que Castillo
pidiera la la confianza y tal Entonces
es muy probable que que que que que no
que no llegue a terminar el mandado Sí
así es que todo continua tal como está
que no llegue les pregunto la derivada
de Castillo es un duro golpe para esa
izquierda lugares Rurales del Perú que
lo vieron con su momento como una
esperanza de outsider pero que estaba
más impregnado de los males del país al
final de lo que hacía esperar su
condición de outsider por mi parte
pienso que sí yo de lo que estoy
escuchando fuera de Lima es un gran
pesar es una es algo que reactiva la
idea que no es falsa de que Lima decide
por el resto del país y que no se
considera a los peruanos y las peruanas
de fuera de la capital y creo que esto
es lo el sentir un sentimiento Pedro
Castillo representaba eso fuera de que
si tenía o tuvo un accionar político
válido capacitado lo que significaba
fuera del país era que ese otro Perú
estaba representado por primera vez en
nuestra historia la fiscalía en
cualquier caso de la nación había
señalado al mandatario por incluso yo
voy a decir liderar una presunta
organización criminal con el objetivo de
amañar y así lograr ganancias ilícitas
nada distinto a lo que ha pasado otros
mandatarios del Perú Pero en qué punto
está esta investigación bueno se le
había iniciado una investigación
preliminar de hecho es la primera vez
que investigan preliminarmente a un
presidente estando todavía en el cargo
son cinco investigaciones que él tiene
en curso por corrupción hay una más por
haber plagiado supuestamente la tesis de
maestría pero claro ha habido un carga
montona allí en cuanto a investigaciones
Pero también es cierto que hay bastantes
indicios de que la corrupción ha
existido o existe y y bueno no es una
sorpresa porque bueno en fin es el mal
endémico del Perú O sea hay un libro
famosísimo que es historia de la
corrosión en el Perú donde en fin hay
algo que nos atraviesa y tal vez incluso
no sé si una manera de de hacer político
de relacionarse en política
lastimosamente un libro histórico otro
otro de Mario Vargas llosas
conversaciones en la catedral donde dice
esa mítica frase de Pero en qué momento
se jodió El Perú no haciendo
parafraseando a Vargas llosa no
podríamos decir que prácticamente desde
el inicio de la República peruana porque
como historiadora puedo decir que no
hubo un momento en el que el Perú haya
podido
organizar un sistema
estable
democrático dado y orientado hacia las
personas más necesitadas permitir
repasar el historial porque ver a un
mandatario en la cárcel no será una
novedad en el país el expresidente
Alejandro Toledo está en Libertad bajo
fianza en Estados Unidos Alan García se
suicidó antes de que le dictaran prisión
preventiva ollanta humala estuvo en
prisión preventiva aunque ya está libre
Pedro Pablo kuczynski está bajo arresto
domiciliario Martín vizcarra está libre
pero bajo investigación Alberto
fujimoris por ahora el único que cumple
prisión efectiva Castillo sigue su
Estela el historial es de quedarte de
piedra no hay esperanzas para que un día
el país pueda cambiar de alguna forma
este negro historial en el poder a corto
plazo lastimosamente yo creo yo creo que
no yo creo que no porque no hay
actualmente un referente político sino
se dijera hay un líder político alguien
y pueda hacer no últimamente se especula
pero en realidad no como un líder
político sino más bien como algo que
puede ser una una bomba a corto plazo la
figura de de antauro mala pero más bien
como una condensación de El del posible
hartazgo de las personas digamos es muy
probable si es que viene a boluarte no
llega a cumplir su mandato el congreso
sigue siendo un congreso obstruccionista
que es lo que es lo que es y si es que
se produce el hartazgo y en ese momento
tal vez antauroma la logra canalizar
todo ese descontento eres una figura que
está en
que nos están viendo que estén un poco
mal es el hermano del expresidente
ollanta humala y en el 2009 durante el
gobierno de Alejandro Toledo él se él
tomó una una comisaría murieron cuatro
personas y él fue juzgado por el delito
de esa edición o o rebelión que también
el delito porque se le va a juzgar a
Pedro Castillo él estuvo se le condenó
veinticinco años luego se le redujo la
condena recién salió libre este año y
desde entonces bueno se especula que su
figura podría ser en fin vamos a ampliar
el foco el zoom y les quiero preguntar
por dos cosas que están en el fondo de
esta cuestión la corrupción como mal
endémica del país y los referentes la
falta de referentes sociales políticos
que tengan un consenso o una o que
puedan ser respetados
por la opinión pública no sé si les
ocurre algún nombre de consenso Y por
qué Y si la corrupción no está lo
suficientemente perseguida en Perú
pienso por mi parte creo que no es el
único país en el que la corrupción sea
de tal amplitud sobre todo en la región
latinoamericana sin embargo el problema
creo que en Perú es ese desfase entre la
capital la capital Lima son
prácticamente diez millones de
habitantes un tercio de la población
total del país
históricamente es el lugar del Poder y
de la concentración del poder hay una
concentración muy fuerte y hace que
entonces un fenómeno que existe en otras
partes aquí se vuelva como que a la
potencia 10 no está mucho más
de manera más este enquistada en este
espacio y por eso es que a los procesos
de regionalización de descentralización
no han tenido un verdadero efecto sino
el de repercutir la corrupción de Lima a
las otras regiones entonces
como que cambios estructurales que
debería ser el el los gobiernos y el
país en general para cambiar y modificar
esta situación la Constituyente podría
ser uno de ellos y en todo caso muchas
personas abogan por esa salida de esta
crisis muy interesante intentamos
explicar la crisis política abierta de
la huida hacia delante de Castillo pero
intentando Buscar dónde están esas
claves poniendo el foco de largo alcance
No porque si no yo creo que nos perdemos
en toda esta crisis les pregunto por qué
la corrupción no está lo suficientemente
perseguida como lo hacía con lizel en el
país y si se les ocurre algún nombre de
referente político de consenso en Perú
en guión porque simplemente yo creo que
lo político viven de esa economía
informal en Perú hay una economía
informal tan grande tan fuerte que
aprovecha tanto los élites de las élites
limeñas que tanto los demás del país en
la selva en la sierra en la costa y Y
eso lo vemos en Perú en Perú hay una una
conexión muy grande pero de un lado la
corrupción hay dos fases a las personas
que van a decir sí no no queremos más
corrupción pero del otro lado le
aprueban le aprueban porque no quieren
que haya una economía formal no quiere
que haya un nuevo contrato social en lo
que esperan hoy día los peruanos y que
no tienen desde más más de diez años
eres una corrección endémica que
impregna el sistema y que incluso es
aceptada dentro de lo que es el sistema
en Sí porque yo creo que el ciudadano
también se ha dado cuenta que es la
única manera de mover las cosas de
alguna manera si es que uno Espera a que
el estado las instituciones funcionen
Digamos si hablamos en temas de Salud si
uno quiere conseguir una cama en un
hospital y si es que uno espera el
proceso tener un mes dos meses de espera
la persona se muere no van a pagar va a
decir OK le pago al médico para que no
sé cuánto a la enfermera para que me
deje entrar Entonces yo digo
doy Este ejemplo para ver cómo las
pequeñas cosas la corrupción es una
manera de relacionarse y de avanzar de
continuar en un país como como dice
guillón altamente informal Y ante este
escenario les quiero preguntar
los peruanos se han acostumbrado los
peruanos esta realidad política de
crisis permanente Con qué palabra lo
definirían hay resignación hay enfado
hay ganas de salir a la calle o hay una
Asunción de Cómo es el país Yo creo que
hay todo a la vez todo a la vez por un
lado los peruanos y las personas están
como que acostumbrados cuando sucedió
estos sucesos
del momento de la disolución
del Congreso inmediatamente todo muchas
personas fueron ya es golpe de Estados o
como si algo fue como si fuese algo
natural como si fuese algo fueron a
recoger a los niños todo se se hubo un
momento de de pero tomado no no bajo el
la idea de un pánico sino como algo que
sucede que podía suceder o sea una
perspectiva eso nos indica que en el
Perú esta inestabilidad ha generado de
todas maneras integrar como que podemos
estar en esta situación largo tiempo
pero también un enfado un gran enfado Y
creo que lo estos días pueden ser una
sorpresa también de levantamiento de
organización un poquito más amplia de
los ciudadanos y ciudadanas de a pie
porque no creo que lo vivan de una
manera pienso que no lo viven de una
manera
feliz entonces
resignación indignación enfado
le ponemos a esta crisis El sentir de
los peruanos y yo pienso que hay uno
rechazo de la política por dos por los
dos lados tanto porque por lo que Pedro
Castillo también hizo pero también por
lo que el congreso hace en los en los
dos lados y del otro lado está cansado
el peruano de siempre ver las mismas
cosas y hoy día Pedro Castillo estaba
justamente esta figura en 2021 de esa
marea Rosa que vemos justamente en el
nivel regional de unos cambios muy
grandes en Suramérica y este este Pedro
Castillo justamente por por muchos en
Perú era voltear la página del
fujimorismo y y al final vemos que no
vemos claro
resignación es la tónica predominante O
sí que hay más irritación Yo diría que
es una son ambas cosas resignación y y
rabia también pero al mismo tiempo
tienes las condiciones de vida del día a
día que no hace Digamos si es que fuera
predominantemente la rabia Y es que
hubiera condiciones para que la gente se
organice podríamos tener algo pero en
fin no es que haya mucho tiempo no es
que ella tampoco no se partió políticos
que inviten al tema no es que haya
organizaciones que sean o sea
organizaciones de partidos políticos hay
en algún momento eso se perdió
probablemente después del fujimorismo
tal vez el issel puede decir Mejor A qué
momento empezó esta crisis de partidos
políticos pero es cierto que que
ha sido muy interesante analizar toda
esta crisis con ustedes nos han dado
muchísimas claves a los que no somos de
Perú para poder entenderla y a todos
ustedes nos vemos la próxima semana
quien en Primera Plana gracias
[Música]